hey I love kid yeah I love hearing that
it makes me happy I hope you still like
it after my first question so I'm
starting with a big one because I love
talking about the idea of going from
first feature to Second feature because
I feel like there's a lot of
misunderstandings out there in terms of
it not necessarily being easier to get
your second feature off the ground so
part on that what is a misconception
about getting the green light on your
second film after your first film Soares
but then also what is something about
the Harder They Fall that helped you get
the book of Clarence made and made the
way you wanted okay so um the first film
took 15 years to make minimum 15 years
right the second film took about 6
minutes to get house because the first
film was so um successful so the second
film was just an easy like people were
expecting it and you have a name place
but then also you know um you need
people that understand your brand of of
art or your brand of crazy or your brand
of expression we had that with legendary
and so it was really easy to get to get
made
um what I would say about the hard of
day fall which was different than the
book of Clarance is the day before we
started filming the hard they fall
remember I've been trying to make this
movie for 15 years or over and the day
before we started filming the whole
world shut down with this new EP uh
worldwide pandemic called the Corona
virus we couldn't even say the name of
it so then when we got up to shoot uh I
I had to wear face shield face mask
goggles couldn't stand I I directed the
whole film not being able to stand
closer than six feet to any actor it was
absolute craziness whereas I didn't have
that on on this movie I had pure
unadulterated
Freedom as Omar C says in this movie
which is a throwback to Mel Gibson in
Braveheart you got a bunch of good Past
movie nods in this one that I also I
like your brand of crazy so I hope
legendary sticks in that business so
incredible Ensemble here which role
would you say was the easiest to cast
where like the right person magically
appeared to you but then I also want to
know the most difficult character to
find the perfect fit for okay you know
it's crazy
because all of these roles would have
been super hard to cast but I started
casting it when I was making a harder
Day fall Clarence would have been
impossible the cast he has all of these
he's Street he's cool but he's really
geeky he's nerdy he's sensitive he's
emotional he's tough when he fights he
would have been impossible to cast but
the day I met Lei Stanfield when I was
casting Cherokee bill in the harder Day
fall I went I called my sister T I have
Clarence I have Clarence I found him T
it's that guy Le he's all of the things
as soon as we spoke in real life and
then his um right-hand man RJ Kyler I
knew I had them both when I was making a
hard day fall obviously the world didn't
know I had this other movie called The
Book of Clarence coming up even though I
nod to it in that film so they were the
would have been the two hardest but they
were I found them uh earlier and then I
think
um
barabus barabus so perfect he is amazing
Omar SE I remember when he when he first
got to Mata where we shot I called my
mom and I said Mommy Mommy I've I've
been arrested she was like what I've
been arrested the police are after me no
son what's happened I it's okay Mommy I
have someone that's going to bail be out
she who I turned the camera around Lup L
my mom was like oh my God Lup we love
you we love you Lup and he would have
been a super hard person to cast but as
soon as I I set my eye my sights on him
I've always been lucky when it comes to
Casting people and and you know he
agreed he agreed to do it I actually
asked him would you have done this had
we not met he no no English is not my
first language it's it's it's beautiful
but it's crazy I had to meet you know
you are crazy I said oh I go on a crazy
ride again I kind of crazy I like it so
of all of your really ambitious set
pieces in this movie going into filming
which one did you think was going to be
the toughest to pull off and then
ultimately was that really the toughest
or did a different one Catch You by
surprise I mean the set pieces here were
really the The Chariot race at the
beginning we got some amazing set pieces
in this movie um The Chariot race at the
beginning would have been um uh hard to
pull off and it was hard but there was
just mad surprises like Tiana Taylor
just like riding her Chariot and and
running she was awesome and then Leith
and arj and the way they embraced the
horses and The Chariot so while it was a
a tricky thing to pull off it was really
enjoyable and and hard and then the
gladiator
fight I thought it was going to be much
harder because I didn't realize and this
was my my my um fault because Leith is
so is so in touch with his emotions and
the movies he's done you don't realize
how much of a physical actor he is this
guy was jumping over I hope they show
the outtakes with me um trying to do the
same movie that he does with my PA
Amanda but he was jumping rolling over
um Omar's back and holding the sword and
they were just super physical um guy so
it went much um easier I don't think
anything was hard to shoot physically
the things were hard to shoot
emotionally like the um the crucifixion
scenes they were real hard um to shoot
and you know tear jerking as we're as
we're doing them oh absolutely those two
action set pieces though very well
photographed you could just see how like
the little details and the inserts
amplify those sequences tfold yeah
that's my that's my um my guy Rob Hardy
the
my he um shot Mission Impossible Fallout
which I believe is one of the greatest
action movies of all time I think it's
because it's new why we don't give it
that um but I put Mission Impossible
Fallout against French Connection I put
Mission Impossible Fallout against heat
I put Miss just with regards to the
action sequences in it it's it's amazing
and so I needed that guy cuz I knew once
I had Rob then I can accomplish All The
Madness of King James oh yes oh yes that
is a top tier Mission Impossible movie
you're spot on with that big question
but I love highlighting somebody's
promising future so what is a film
making goal you have for yourself that
now feels more Within Reach than ever
because the book of Clarance exists you
know it's an interesting thing I don't
necessarily have um film making goals I
have rules obey your
crazy my first movie I took everyone
back 150 years right 130 years to the
old west my second movie I took everyone
back 200000 years to the New Testament
I'm literally the physical
personification of obey your crazy
every single thought you have in your
head and all your ideas you have those
thoughts and ideas for reason you're
meant to follow them and don't let
anyone sealing your destinations with
their own limitations and so for me
that's who I am as a as a filmmaker
people think think uh um I've made like
some big statements now boy I'm just
getting started yeah that's what I like
to hear I feel like obey you're crazy is
definitely the headline of this article
so you've done a Biblical movie you've
done a western is there another genre
you're eager to tackle next absolutely
I'm going to tackle all the genres
sci-fi I'm going I'm going everywhere
give me a horror movie give me a horror
movie with your brand of crazy I'll give
you a horror movie but I have to shoot
the horror movie on
iPhones the whole thing on iPhones
actually got one I that I want to do uh
I could probably shoot it in a break but
I have to shoot it all on iPhones the
iPhones is an amazing device that era we
had of all of those independent
filmmakers Quinton tantina Robert
Rodriguez Edward Burns when they all
came out in the early early '90s I
believe if that movement happened now
everyone would be using iPhones these
devices are are amazing and I have an
idea I want to shoot on um on iPhones
but it's it's real scary real scary okay
okay I'm here for it I'm going to wait
very impatiently for that and say
congratulations on the book of pance
thank you so much and and uh I love
kider so this is a
joy